but then but sociopath so genders like
that kid from who created the Silk Road
who did the yeah is the black market
drug trading great I need the dark web
the dark yeah the dark web essentially
he got to life since he's 26 years old
yet to life since yeah yeah Ross
Ulbricht yeah Stevie talks to him yeah I
know I'm starting to see you about on
the plane super fascinating yeah I
looked into it like holy [ __ ] what a
story
dead Pirate Roberts I guess they did
exact because there was major drug
trafficking and even hits like assassin
he ordered like five hits on people he
did yeah he did yeah
well then you gotta go to jail that's
why I said to Stephen seems like well
they can't prove that like now if you
they order them if you ordered did you
know how the fascinations you know how
they got it to is you know they you
didn't know who people were on there
really so they had an undercover agent
pretend he was he took over somebody's
account so they arrested one guys
account he all that information so
undercover cop pretended he was that
account
it was a K we got a problem he's like
alright get rid of music right semi 200
grand I'll take care of your problem
which was the hit and this supposing
Ross sent that money then again they
kept sent him up this person this person
so he ordered like five hits for hire
well I mean that's that's the products
that's mean a lot guys murder five
people he is in but all for all he knows
those murders were done because all it
was all fake the cops do yeah they're
good they're good they're not dumb it's
like so so my boy this friend of Mines
nephew got put in jail he was dealing
drugs and he goes he goes yeah but they
told me that they they were just want to
talk to me a my buddy who you know goes
hey dude feds lie sometimes to criminals
when they're trying to catch them that's
what they do sometimes because you're
doing a major crime it's part of police
work you're [ __ ] idiot so he went to
jail yeah I mean they kept huge balls he
was all set up by these guys you went to
like like a cafe in San Francisco and
they're like y'all wait from it along a
certain thing because if you don't log
into that
enclosed computer he's so good with
computers that app will shut down like
you kid no one can ever access it and he
knows this so it's what these feds did
they got him there he's talking to the
February thinks another guy like Iceland
some and he goes hey I need you to jump
on this account confirm so they knew
that he was inside what they need to see
they had to fake feds getting an
argument behind him and as he logged in
he heard argument turned and he turned
the feds grabbed his computers because
they knew it was open and they kept it
open arrested him and they kept it open
the whole time and just download all
Baha all the data genius and his
argument was he's like well I sold the
company I said I'm not part of I sold it
years ago I'm not part of it but then
they have content they take the person
goes the guy goes he's a former owner of
something like built another something
like that and he goes does anybody know
he goes to people and he goes wool [ __ ]
that's not giddy OHS don't worry they
think I sold it can of [ __ ] I mean kind
of [ __ ] it yeah but I like talking
with Stevie like see I get so Stevie
telling about storm like that's [ __ ]
up due to year like that thing is an
awful place nobody hears and with that
source in El Chapo saw a whole lot and
all around the plane I'm research on
simple research simple background search
tonight do I so is a to almost three
hour plane ride I read the report for
two hours I Stevie here's why you do we
try killing five people
he's to offer his knowledge he thought
those people were murdered tells five
people wolves in his mind but in his
meyer your who's down to Hillary I'll
kill her yeah you know he got the
kingpin rule if you run a drug
organization you're the kingpin you get
the [ __ ] books don't it they made him
like the you know poster boy yeah
and CVS no he never got charred there
was also sex trafficking around the dark
web there was no he not dark web hood so
his his thing wasn't that he's some road
his Silk Road was drugs mainly drugs and
weapons
oh not never people said shopping okay
at the time was just drugs I think it
was used so be encrypted technology he
could have used for all that so
eventually yeah yeah there was a weird
story about this really gorgeous model
in England who is
kidnapped by these she said Romanian or
you know Albanian sex traffickers and
they were going to they put an ad on on
the web for to have sex with her they
were gonna force her to have sex because
she was like you know really beautiful
and kind of a little bit famous and then
the guy found out she was a mother and
he let her go I remember this I thought
she made it up I don't know did she make
it up cuz it sounds made out it sounds
like if you're bad enough to kidnap a
woman and put her up on the dark web for
you know [ __ ] I thought it was fate
abate remember we felt it was fake yeah
right abduction of Chloe ailing BAE's
bears pastry model had traveled him and
on it late for a fake photo shoot there
she was abducted by two individuals
claiming to be members of a criminal
organization called the Black Death
group alright hold on the music what
else did it say there and top clothes
national from the United Kingdom was
convicted in a Milan Court of the
kidnapping and sentences sixteen years
and nine months in prison Wow
and as of June 2019 the trial of a
suspected accomplice his older brother
Michael her about remains in progress so
it is true yeah it was just fishing when
we first read it right yeah something
was just sounds so crazy I know
[ __ ] publicity stunt although later
became clear from this way that she was
not involved Wow
so me was just a ransom email it was
like a kidnapping really [ __ ] strange
man yeah it was funny was Stevie's like
did he I just mean him used to write
back and forth oh my god that's such a
shame dude I think that's awful there
hey it's Stevie J killing 15 he was they
never proved that they actually threw
those out I go yeah cuz there he got him
for double life sentence so that I can a
waste taxpayers money on get him for
this well I don't know what thrown it
out I mean I don't know I mean if it
sold out they set it up though for where
he was actually paying the money and
correct yeah I mean I see God's
knowledge in it
well that's that is murder
you talk to Stevie and you talk was in
the kids mom they're saying it's all
fake that was at him he was all set up
this woman another guy was running they
do this all time when people want to
kill their spouses for insurance money
or whatever and they they get you they
the cops will get wind of it and they'll
pose as a hitman and they give you a
chance they always say you sure you want
to go through with this they give you a
chance to back out when you don't they
close in on you they arrest you and oh
but sometimes heat you know what's
amazing this one woman had it done she
was she only did a year in prison it's
like how are you doing here you should
do a [ __ ] life to me he's a
good-looking kid man all right I mean I
would say that I would he looks like he
looks like the guy from I didn't talk to
Leah
Ross Pattinson Robert Pattinson yes best
thing that kind of micro no what do you
do seen Robert Patterson yeah I love him
out of sit and I'm saying hi Vincent
Davis the new Batman well I don't agree
with that I mean I don't see that much
of a difference dude let's see that's
Batman dude bad they look similar yeah
looks like his little brother who became
a hacker yeah yeah a little brother that
never leaves the basement everything
good looking good yeah not bad not what
you expect from a hacker right he's no
Batman I'm not not a master criminal I
guess you know man I would say the
master villain
no I'm saying dark he doesn't look like
a master Allah no no no no but my thing
is is like he couldn't he'd be an ally
for a government if he's that smart can
we use them for what's going on now okay
Houston I can say that's what I'm saying
instead of you know basically you ruined
this kid's world his life can we use
them as an ally they don't they don't
need him they have a lot of really smart
hackers
you know I'm saying you can't rely on
someone like that also if you've
murdered if you've if you tried to
murder keep off the murders the the
thing I can't get over now if you talk
to you spear Cedars and like Sam Tripoli
and those guys they're gonna tell you
that he was all set up
real well that's not how the FBI works
usually I would imagine
wait why it was jared leto I'm trying to
open it but it's not loading your son
that's what I'm guessing he's probably
to play him because it is a crazy story
crazy crazy I just bought the book
there's supposed to be a really New York
Times best-selling book - and then you
know Steve because he's friend Steve you
know the books like I guess when he's
hot killing people he's like yeah
[ __ ] killing me think he didn't talk
like that like well they have his
texture so yeah yeah be interesting to
see the real story Ross Ulbricht but
dude he's never getting out of jail oh
dude he can't even there's no there's no
he's lining up for parole Bubba it's to
life sentence plus 40 years well you're
never getting out of jail do you know
it's heartbreaking they thought he was
only get 20 years I guess Steve is
stalking him he's like dude it's 20
years can you imagine then he and then
he goes in and he he gives the you know
the the judge this he gets up and goes
you know I've I know I've done crime and
you know I've I'm gonna lose my middle
you I'm gonna lose my adult life don't
let me lose my my old man please give me
the old man life that I have and they're
like yeah cool story to life sentence
plus 40 years he thought is it going in
it was it because they were trying to
make an example of him or yeah cause
he's like the first [ __ ] you remember
this is 2008 110 that's a really loud
yeah I get this freaking teeth but he
was the first like crypto currency like
all right you know they made an example
there may example but he put it again
the kingpin charge because I don't see
at masterminds on there well set on
drugs without getting caught but all
that and also also what else they're
saying is how many people Odie's on all
the drugs I know but that's not see
that's I don't put that on it no me
neither that I put that on he traded a
platform who chooses to do drugs and all
I don't put that on I don't even put on
him if he was this entrepreneurial kid
who figured out a way to make money and
move drugs
I think drugs should be legal cuz I
don't believe this war on drugs has been
very helpful but that's not the way
that's true what I'm saying is that I
give you 20 years
given twenty years I would be like those
life sentences but now if you're trying
to kill five people stuff now I got a
huge profit that's not now now I'm like
up well you're [ __ ] you're you that's
the height of immorality you're actually
murdering that's the hiccup whoo you
can't murder you can't try to matter
that into one person really vile those
people cuz you know Stevie told me it's
a bunch of malarkey and they did throw
it out but I think see federal
prosecutors allege that over ket paid
seven or thirty thousand dollars and
murder for hire details talking at least
five people alleged alleged because he
threatened yeah the they threatened to
out and basically prosecutors believe no
contract killing occurred or actually
not charged in the trial in New York
filler with any murder for hire but
evidence was introduced at trial
supporting the allegations the elegance
the evidence that Albrecht had
commissioned murders was considered by
the judge in sentencing allbrook to life
there you go and was a factor in the
second courtesans to affirm the life
sentences a separate incident against
Albrecht in federal court in Maryland on
a single murder for hire charge alleging
that he he contracted to kill one of his
employees a former Silk Road moderator
was prejudiced by prosecutors in July 18
to 2018 after his New York conviction
and sentence became final so I don't
think they want to pursue it like what
else where the gasket where you god I
mean but that makes sense if you're the
judge and you're gonna go dude I mean
for whatever technical reason we know
that you did this because he's looking
at evidence that's that would be my
thing and it crazy though that's been so
he made it first and was made his own
because he was like he was in Austin he
was like doing stuff and it was wasn't
successful and had no money and had a
girlfriend and then he came up with this
idea and critten and came up with his
own shrooms mm-hmm and sold those he's
again they sold fast and I can't trace
anything to me it's nothing she opened
it up so but the fear has always been if
someone to do this he controls
everything so the fair would and you
know I can't call the feds or the cops
like hey this guy took money so the fair
is they have all this cryptocurrency in
there let's say gets up to 20
million well he has access to all of it
because any transaction he take ten
percent but he was in you could see all
the transactions so the scare was if you
didn't trust them I'm sure people have
done before all the money gets in there
and then he takes in a run which
happened after he got charged another
one came up you know like Silk Road 2.0
and then others came up and then one got
up I think all the way to 18 million
they had 18 million like the whole thing
and they just dipped out and I never
found him so everyone lost their money
[ __ ] this cash now I know a guy who was
equipped on currency one a few first
guys to create cryptocurrency and he had
bodyguards with him all time because
they were afraid that I murdered that
guy organized-crime would kidnap him and
then you know
it make sense because the kind of guys
that dealin cryptocurrency a lot of
times they're not they're not then why
cuz the only one know in their moves I
mean you know yeah you got some rough
dudes I don't know anything about that
world cryptocurrency or the dark web or
Silk Road well cuz you're not a criminal
I know but like even if you took but
again if you talked to Jay like with the
dark web and like you you have to know
so much stuff just to gain access to get
on there Jesus just a game just you up
there like know all this like legalized
ramming lien yeah yeah I'm everybody
knows I always forget it exists there's
a dartle web but but even just like
we're not even in the [ __ ] realm but
also how you so as I joined the dark web
Brendan like do you have like a pass or
is there an app I downloaded I would you
buy how would you buy stuff on there to
if it's like you want to buy crack you
of cocaine alright I go yeah I get the
money then you send it you can't trace
it yeah they send it they send it
somewhere I mean if I was a cop I just
set those down and I don't [ __ ] know
what I do but they can trace all because
you have to in order to be part of the
club I don't help dark web works they
have no [ __ ] I'm talking about but on
Silk Road you have to submit your driver
license in like five grand just to get
in the club but then you got another
program and [ __ ] like uploading
what I'm out dude I don't need drugs
I'll go to the [ __ ] Venice to get my
drug yeah also I'm not I'm not looking
to buy uranium from from a Russian
scientist yes I get I get mine trying to
take over the world
yeah what the [ __ ] to do dude but it's
just like when I was reading up on I'm
like the the work there's a whole nother
world when I even can sit we're not even
pardon out we are not we're not even we
are not part of it but Cyberman thought
tick tock was confusing the dark web is
a big [ __ ] thing man right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]